[Music]
three years from now
if you had to place a bet
it doesn't have to be a large bet but if
you just had to
take a position in
what things might look like with respect
to free speech
what picture would you paint
in as much or as little detail as you
would like
i think that in three years
the largest players
in
[Music]
whatever platforms emerge metaverse or
other platforms
are going to be under a lot of pressure
to do the kind of content moderation and
regulation
of speech and conduct
that happened in web 2.0
and it's not just going to be speech
it's going to be stuff you do because if
the metaverse turns out to work really
well you're not just going to talk to
people there right in theory everything
you're doing on twitter is talking right
you're writing so you're speaking
but if you were in a fully immersive
experience you can also do stuff
you know you can play games you can
punch people virtually you can kiss them
virtually you know every other human
activity presumably you can engage in
virtually that's conduct it's not just
talking and so it's not even clear that
free speech would be the normal model to
apply to it i mean you can imagine
someone saying well that's all speech
because it's virtual and maybe someone
would think that that might turn out to
be right but it actually will i think
feel a lot more like conduct i think
already
some of the virtual platforms that
people use on the metaverse feel a lot
more like doing stuff than they do like
saying stuff so i think there'll be huge
pressure
for the companies in the first instance
to regulate the stuff that people can do
and say
and if the companies don't do it i think
there's going to be a lot of pressure on
the government to do it and so i think
that especially if the metaverse in
three years is good enough that people
are spending a reasonable amount of time
doing stuff there it will have to be
subject to pretty substantial internal
private regulation and given that
i think that
the kind of free speech from the
government that people want may continue
to exist but i don't think people are
going to be able to do whatever they
want in every
subpart of the metaverse i think there
will be parts where it's do whatever you
want
you know
first-person shooter against you against
the world do whatever you want anybody
there'll be places to go and do that but
i think if you want the vast majority of
people to spend a lot of time in a space
it has to be pretty orderly
and it would be lovely if human beings
could order themselves spontaneously
but we don't have a lot of evidence that
they've ever managed to do that in the
past and the idea that they're going to
do that the next three years in the
metaverse seems pretty implausible to me
yeah we have a very strong lord of the
flies history behind us i'm not sure
that uh human nature will turn on a dime
yeah and we'll turn into the
angels of our better nature immediately
uh one can hope you know
one can hope it'd be nice it'd be nice
any other i don't want to call them
predictions speculations for what we may
also see three years from now i mean it
seems to me
if i had to bet i think there's going to
be a strong
centralized nature to what many would
hope would be decentralized
metaverses or a metaverse i simply think
the discovery process the
interoperability issues and so on may be
so thorny also the
frankly the
policing or moderating of conduct will
become such a priority for so many
players that
for those and other reasons many will
choose
centralized
companies or organizations rather than
decentralized
options that seems inevitable to me even
within
web 3 if you think about a lot of what
dictates behavior you find
centralized taste makers why because for
each individual to have the
responsibility to sort through the noise
to read the code to look at the smart
contracts to audit to do all these
things themselves is simply not feasible
unless you have infinite time on your
hands and the capabilities
so i do think
i'm fascinated by decentralization and
uh have invested very heavily in
web 3 and related technologies but
nonetheless i do think
people crave
centralized sort of authority and
standards on some level at least enough
people do that will have strong
centralized players but
that's just my speculation
anything else you see
just over the next
say three years that you would
expect to see
yeah there is one other thing that i
think will be really fascinating and
important when we think about what the
next phase of web 3.0 will look like
we probably still don't fully understand
what the
ar vr interplay is going to be
right there's still people who say it's
all going to be vr it's mostly going to
be very people say no it's going to be
mostly bar and i don't you know that's a
really fascinating and hard debate
my guess is it's going to be something
we haven't exactly figured out what it's
going to look like yet but let's assume
for a moment that a substantial part of
this is augmented reality so that it's
not just that we live all of our lives
in this to me dystopian world where we
spend 8 or ten hours a day with a
headset over our eyes you know in a
darkened room
we're still going to have a lot of this
technology but it's probably going to go
with us in some mechanism when we go out
into the world
so now what that does
is it makes it really hard
to work out
what it means to be regulated and what
it means to be free when you're
interacting
in real life with other people and
simultaneously interacting with those
same people or with other people in some
kind of virtual reality or augmented
reality
so the idea is you and i are having this
conversation right now
and
we're connected by the internet and
we're connected by
video and we're connected by audio and
we're creating something in some sense
we're already doing an augmented reality
form of interaction
but if you add in a whole bunch of other
layers and imagine that we're walking
down the street having a conversation on
multiple levels simultaneously which is
not so impossible to imagine since after
all you see people all the time walking
down the street talking to each other
both of them on their phones which is
just a crude version of what presumably
we'll be doing in some in some future
moment
so in that environment
the the really big challenge that i see
coming and i'm really only just starting
to get a sense of this now
and i haven't said this anywhere before
is that
the idea that you have one set of rights
and obligations
to the person you're talking to in real
life and another set of rules and
obligations to the person you're engaged
with in augmented reality at the same
moment
is gonna be it's not gonna work
it's not gonna work to have two
different regulatory regimes
involving the two of us at the same time
and if the government regulates what we
can do to each other in real life
and a private company regulates what we
can do to each other in this ar vr kind
of space simultaneously it's going to
get really messy and really confusing
you know what if you insult me or i
insult you in some way that we would not
be allowed to do on the virtual
engagement but that we're perfectly
permitted to do interpersonally or flip
it the other way what if you punch me in
augmented reality or virtual reality
which you wouldn't be legally allowed to
do
on the street because the cops would
arrest you
but i feel just as punched or maybe not
just as punched but very punched in some
in some dimension
if we really get so my takeaway here is
this if we really get some complex mixed
ar vr mix
it's not sustainable
to have two totally disparate regulatory
regimes one coming from the government
and one coming from the private
companies and so this is a little bit
intention with what i said before what i
was saying before was that my base case
is that we are going to have mostly
private regulation in these virtual
spaces
and continue to have mostly government
regulation in real life what i'm saying
now is
if we get this kind of really complexly
mixed arvr thing
that that equilibrium will not be
sustainable we'll have to move towards
some much more unified integrated
kind of regulatory regime
and
that's going to be fascinating and it's
going to be really extremely extremely
complicated
my oh my the adventures ahead
you